foreign
another sacred cow and I wrote about
this in my email to you
one of the truths that I learned and I
was really allergic to learning this one
because
it is so sacred
hope is the measure of future regrets
hope is
thought of us
something that can only be good
but maybe that's just a dressed up way
of saying expectation or even a Chase of
sorts
what uh
what
what is your understanding of Hope
it's just more pot in the sky
it's one just because you hope for
something it doesn't mean it's going to
happen
now if you
if you set the things in place for it to
happen
then you set them in place
but hope has nothing to do with anything
what's hope going to do
you hoping for something doesn't make it
any more likely of it becoming true
so
everyone is conditioned to like things
that are
flowery and Glee and nice
and have a nice scent
and pretty words
and they look good on the rectangular
shape of a bumper sticker
and they're just nice
and that's fine
once again no evil
but it's just Pie in the Sky
it's just it's just a bunch of niceties
hope for this
be kind be compassionate be this be that
as if you walk around with 95 switches
and you forgot to turn them on
and now turn on the Hope switch and then
the compassions which then the kindness
which oh I forgot to turn like you're
full of that's like you're a breaker box
and oh I forgot to oh I forgot I'm glad
you reminded me from the kindness I left
that one off last night
it's juvenile
if things worked that way
that someone says be hopeful and be kind
and be compassionate
then everybody would be hopeful kind and
compassionate
and there would be no policemen and
there'd be no courtrooms you would just
say did you do that and the guy would
say yes I stole all this and that okay
then you're in jail thank you very much
okay there's no reason for lawyers and
and normally for anything right
if all those things worked
then there'd be no reason for anything
everything would be nice and he'd be
compassionate to you and you'd be
mindful to him and he'd be it's it's
just fairy tales and it's just fairy
tales for adults
that's all it is it's instead of cartoon
characters they implant real flesh and
blood human beings you know instead of
instead of having diagrams in the in the
pop-out picture books they just put it
in paragraph form
it's just tabloids and fairy tales
because it sounds nice and everyone
wants to hear nice things and do nice
things and that's fine
never will you hear me say that you
shouldn't do that
it's but it's just it doesn't it doesn't
take away from the fact that it's pie in
the sky but people want pie in the sky
in my own life I've
noticed hope
often getting in the way it's almost a a
clutter of sorts I remember when I used
to play basketball back in high school
you would hope that you make the free
throw right but you hope so much that
you actually impede your ability to make
the free throw but I think that happens
that permeates a bunch of other areas
in my life I hope this person likes me I
hope I can accomplish this I hope I get
this award or reward
hoping for the Applause makes the
Applause much less
worthwhile it it almost
so putting a wet blanket on it if you
if I need it
and then get it then it's simply
fulfilling
the
the expectation that I had
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free